hello everyone and welcome to the
closing ceremony of the 2019 sinfield
cup we had a fantastic tournament very
exciting all the way to the very end and
we emerged with a victor it was simply
thrilling for all to see well first of
all i'd like to thank shannon bailey and
the world chess hall of fame for hosting
the event
[Applause]
this event would not occur without the
wonderful generosity of two amazing
people please give a warm hand to dr
jeanne and rex singfield
there are many people behind the scenes
to thank but for the grand chest tour of
which this event is a part we'd like to
thank mike karkovsky graham jurgensen
and tony rich along with joy bray for
their collaboration and all their
efforts
[Applause]
and of course there are many sponsors
around the world certainly jill beth
hauser with coliers international
vivendi the sponsors in abhijan and
paris and game plan those in bucharest
and also in zagreb and calcutta thank
you so much to the sponsors for making
the grand chess tour such an amazing
event
[Applause]
we will save our thanks for one
visionary a little bit later in the
broadcast as he will speak as well
but for now we will ask the executive
director of the chess club the big dog
tony rich to say a few words
thank you
thank you all for joining us here the
singfield cup is really our our flagship
event each year it brings together the
best players in the world who compete
across a couple of weeks in town
and this year was nothing but
spectacular i mean it was really great
to watch all of the games thank you all
for making it such an exciting event
you know the club has been around for 11
years now
and i've been lucky that i've been part
of it since day one uh we started in
2009 by hosting our first national event
with the us championship we moved on the
next year to add the junior championship
and every year we try to do something
more and add something new you know the
singfield cup has been around for seven
years now if you can believe it we've
been lucky we've had a different winner
each year
and so i can only say that the future
for the saint louis chess club really
looks bright i'd like to acknowledge
carol meyer who's here carol is the
executive director of u.s chess
and has been a great partner with the st
louis chess club really since its
inception so carol thanks for joining us
here tonight
[Applause]
i'd also like to thank my team um you
know they really do an amazing job and
they make
these events what they are rebecca
buffington emily trask
beth deacon
jonathan schrantz all of the all of the
folks my comer everybody at the st louis
chess club what's interesting is they
each have these unique roles where they
each do something
big or small
that really comes together and makes
this something special so thanks to all
of you as well
[Applause]
those of you that were here for the
opening ceremony of the saint louis
rapid and blitz know that i wasn't and
it was uh the first one that i missed it
was because i was actually at the us
open at the the governance meetings the
delegates meetings and also to attend um
the awards ceremony where dr jeanne
sinkfield received the meritorious
service award um i was lucky enough to
be able to stand on stage right next to
carol meyer and we're both holding up
jeannie's book learn to read and write
chess it really is for the novice player
and it's a great opportunity to get your
kids and your friends and your family
introduced to the game as well so that's
a long way of saying it's my pleasure to
introduce to you dr jeanne singfield
[Applause]
right before the tournament we were uh i
was talking to some of the players about
side bets
and one of them was you know the you
know top two players bobby and magnus
would they win
and then i was betting the five who've
won before against the ones who have
never won
and no one would take that bet
so i am
and we have had this this is our seventh
year five years a row we had a different
person win
and they were sitting here
raise your hand all five
mlv
magnus bobby
wesley and i'm very very happy that we
haven't broken our record and we have a
brand new winner because it's in the
water in st louis
ding from china
[Applause]
so the
don't the betting thing didn't work this
year so next year right
so i get to introduce rex okay rex does
high stuff so
all these crazy tournaments are
his
imagination
because he thinks that if we want to
grow chess around the world we have to
show them the best players in the world
right here are the best players in the
entire world for chess how about a hand
for these guys
and obviously since i'm teaching kids
how to read and write chess and my boy
scouts all 250 000 of them playing chess
i'm working on this level
so
next year i may really you know i'll
step up you know i might get a 600
rating
so it's my pleasure to introduce my
husband
the godfather of american chess rex
infield
[Applause]
thank you genie well first of all i
would like to
thank all of the players for an
incredibly outstanding performance with
all the draws that we were all
complaining about it just created a
crescendo of excitement at the end
and as i mentioned the last ceremony uh
this is always my favorite time of the
year in saint louis as the great players
come to town but it's joined with a
moment of sadness and maldipe amira
so and uh that is as they start to leave
town
but it's had it's been an honor of
having all of you here again and i want
you to know i checked with the mayor of
st louis and you are all welcome to stay
and live here
so let's give another great round of
applause for these fabulous performers
[Applause]
so i also want to thank our the best
commentary teams of any sport in the
world period i assert that every time
but
i say that because it's true
with maurice and jen
and yasser
and muriel and elmira and christian and
alejandro all of you do an amazing job
and the audience internationally gets
bigger and bigger and i think the
audience in kingside gets bigger and
bigger as well
so and then also i want to thank the
staff of the chess club in the hall of
fame who bring everything together
they're sort of the behind the scenes
people that makes everything work it
looks smoothly but it's smooth because
of what they do
and especially thanks to joy who is
the great overseer and to tony rich the
executive director shannon bailey of
this hall of fame and all of the staffs
that support both of them is just truly
amazing and i can't thank you enough
and i want to thank also all the
contractors and vendors who make
everything possible my son randy and his
team at spectrum studios kitay
silverback eric mosel who designs and
creates all the graphics for the show
which are truly amazing i always wonder
how do we get so many and change them so
quickly so he does an amazing job
and ben simon and isaac schrantz who
handle the production of the russian
commentary and all of those that make
the broadcast and live show an
incredible success
now at the opening ceremony we unveiled
no there's a typo here it says we
unveiled sinfield tables that is not
true we unveiled nate cullen tables
nate where are you
right there thank you very much nate
lives in central missouri about 10 miles
15 miles from our place outside of
westphalia
and he's won several national
championships for woodworking i think at
the starting at the young age of 16 or
17. so you're like in this company their
company you know for doing great things
at young ages
so i hope the tape that the players
enjoyed the comfort and beauty of these
new tables as you all know they are
modeled on the tables that was used in
havana cuba in 1960 and 1966. i would
like to say i invented something but i
didn't i stole the idea i know a good
idea when i steal it
so
and now it's a pleasure to introduce
truly the brains behind and the
visionary of the grand chest tour grand
master gary kasparov
[Applause]
thank you very much rex uh
um okay i have to start again saying
thank you very much rex
ginny for having us all of us here and
obviously congratulations to dingleren
for
greater victory undoubtedly your best
result yet
so that young you know just
this place and time to grow up
um uh i i would like to say a few words
about the event itself because it's
it it
it comes time and again that we hear all
these cries over internet about the end
of classical chess
and
you know
i just have thought this morning that if
it's not for saint louis
it may be true
so it's very important that you know is
this at the time where classical chess
looks for many as an extinct
item in this just menu there's a place
where classical she has not just played
but celebrated
and i have to say that all participants
they they were up to the highest
standards highest expectations of rex
and genie so
yeah there were many draws but you know
it's this how many games in soccer end
up you know scoreless draws or just you
know one one uh side scores at the very
end
and uh for those who say oh we are sick
and tired of seeing the same faces all
the time
uh i just thought okay how many years
federer is playing tennis
yeah it's the and nobody complains about
the same people you know just playing
time and again the finals in in in
australia in paris in london in new york
open they're simply the best
you know just how can you complain about
the best players you know coming back
and again and
yeah i have just to you know say that
i was rooting for vision this this time
yes yeah we had no we had because okay
look it's it's yeah probably age tells
yes but it's yeah it's our generation
but it's just you know it's uh it's
amazing you know it's at age 50
uh sorry it's just it's not yet yes
yeah almost yes oh yeah you're almost
there so yeah it's i mean he can play
such a fresh chest and it says okay he
was not lucky i had a funny funny
conversation the first time i met first
person i met in the hotel when i arrived
early morning because it was vishy and
said vishal you know i called you robin
hood he said no no you're wrong robin
who took from rich and gave to poor i
took from richard gave it back
yeah but anyway it's it was a great
event and again the draws you know it's
i think it's a stable just result of you
know of um not uh uh
just players being equal but tenacity
it's just it's hard to win the game when
just nobody blunders
or you know just some players just fight
to the to just to the very last pawn
just you know all the resources that
they can find
at the chessboard so i'm now i'm
more than more than happy to be here
again and
and as i thought that you know for
centuries you know it's the the jews
have been saying next year in jerusalem
and uh it became some sort of the it's a
claim for a dream
so that something great will happen next
year maybe in 10 years and when we say
next year since lewis for us is not a
dream
it's it's a reality so next year in
saint louis thank you
thank you gary
well before we get to the prize giving
i'd like to thank a few people who
deserve recognition the chief arbiter
chris byrd and his deputy arbiter karen
pennock
they kept everybody in line make sure
the whip was out just in case thank you
very much
and also our production assistant var
okobian and our grandchild journalist
tatev abrahamian please give a hand to
those
it is indeed a special pleasure to be
able to call
the games of these amazing players
i know jennifer and yasser we sit in
amazement sometimes shaking our heads
that we actually
have this job
it is so such a rare treat an
opportunity to be able to be amongst the
best players in the world on the planet
as gary said and be able to see your
fine games see your struggles we have
sort of been there trying to make our
own moves and we know when the mistakes
come how painful it is and when the
victories come how sweet it is and you
continue to amaze us with your
creativity and your struggles
it is it is indeed a special treat for
me thank you very much for all that you
do for chess and continue to do
but we can only have one winner we'll
recognize some of the top performers in
the event in a tie for third and fourth
place ask these gentlemen to stand and
accept our warm applause grandmasters
vichy anand and sergey karyakin
[Applause]
this year this gentleman is not used to
hearing the word second
but
that's only because he's been so
fabulous the entire year in this
tournament he languished a bit
scoring nine draws in a row it never
happened to him in the sink field cup
not even five draws in a row but he
pulled it together at the very end won
his last two games when he had to when
it counted showing the sign of a
champion of a true champion he came up
just short in the end but don't expect
that to happen too often he is indeed
the finest player on the planet world
champion in second place world champion
magnus carlson
[Applause]
we were treated to an incredible tie
break today
what amazing defense they neutralized
each other in the first two games and
then again in the third in the first
blitz and then a simply magnificent
performance
punchers heavyweight punchers trying to
kill each other in that last game but
only one player could emerge victorious
his entire tournament was one of
tenacity determination fantastic play
couple of games that were just brilliant
will be remembered for a long time to
come i think even gary mentioned his win
against anish geary being one of those
fine positional victories that
will certainly go in his best games book
one day in the future but today is
indeed his day the deserving winner of
the 2019 singfield cup from china grand
master ding lorraine
[Applause]
we asked
genie and rex to take a championship
photo with the winner
we do have a small correction we did
have repeat winners last year it was the
first year where fabi and magnus and
levon did repeat as winners in last year
but a brand new fresh winner in digler
end and
he has
risen
up the rating
an absolutely
wonderful
result
for him as gary said maybe the result of
his career
to date
may he have many
such results as well
thank you rex thank you genie thank you
tony
and we will ask the champion
to say a few words that they're saying
they're going to engrave this one with
his name on it as all of your past
winners have had their names on it as
well
but we will ask him to say just a few
words
please champion
i feel now a little bit nervous
maybe
more nervous than in like
in a game
and
feel my heartbeat
very quickly
just like my game against vici
since i was totally lost out of the
opening so
i think too embarrassed
but first of all i was to want to thank
sinfeld family and the chess club for
organizing this wonderful event
and it's my third time there
and this time i found the forest park
very nice place
and i worked there every day and
it kept me
in a good mood
although it's been a long day and
although i'm not as happy
as
the time i win the tie break
since i have mixed feelings
sometimes i'm
i'm
and also tired
but i must say this was this is a
biggest individual achievement in my
whole career
and
i wish to come back again
next year and to defend the title thank
you
the champion grand master ding loren
ladies and gentlemen
thank you
he's a modest man uh
he speaks softly but boy does he carry a
big stick
and that's it folks for our closing
ceremony this is indeed the fifth stop
on the grand chess tour the final
classical stop we will have two more
stops the next one in bucharest romania
and then the final one
in calcutta india you can go to
granchester.org to find out more of
those there are critical qualifying
spots for london i would say after his
results today or this this event magnus
carl cars
magnus carlsen is
safely
going to get his ticket to london
i don't think he has to play the last
one but magnus uh the indians would be
very angry if you didn't show up for
that one so don't try to bail
but
there are other critical spots at play
and we will find out all of that as the
drama continues to unfold
and we still have another event here in
st louis the summer of chess is not over
we've been here a while but there's
still four
more days of chess as we will drag gary
kasparov out of retirement and he will
play in the chess 960. i believe the
trash talking for that has already begun
fabiano caruana had some words to say
gary you heard them
you did yes okay
that
we know gary is ready for that challenge
we will look forward to that and the
other players who will come to compete
but until then we thank you very much
for your attention your time and
all i can say now is thank you and good
night
[Applause]
[Music]
you